welcome to Tucker Carlson tonight former
congressman Boehner or Roarke gave a
speech to kids at the University of
Virginia yesterday in Charlottesville
maybe you saw it they know had a
microphone he was speaking to a group of
students seated in a small amphitheater
and for a moment if you closed one eye
it looked convincingly like a campaign
event there were volunteers and matching
t-shirts fussing over logistics O'Rourke
himself for a slightly dopey UVA
basketball cap as he spoke because
wearing other people's hats is what
you're supposed to do when you run for
president and to be clear running for
president is what bait or work says he
is doing it's all a little sad when you
think about it a work is not going to be
the president at least of this country
his campaign is dead totally dead they
went toes up last week from a fatal
overdose of Buddha judge not everyone
has heard the news the morning hasn't
yet started but Bay topher president is
done it's over
he's Jeb Bush now future generations
will remember Bay don't work if they
recall him at all really is a media
story remember the guy with a weird
nickname that all the dummies on cable
news fell in love with in a single day
that was bizarre and it was bizarre I
saw him for the first time just a month
ago when he sat down with Oprah and me
and the rest of the people in the
audience thought wow this guy has this
dynamic positive energy yeah he has that
raw talent he is very kind of Obama
asked and indeed the women voted for him
in the suburbs of Houston who hadn't
voted Democrat before because they had a
kind of better crush going on
you know he's wholesome in he's earnest
has that gleam in his eye somebody evan
smith in the texas tribune said seeing
him is like it's like a Jesus Christ
Superstar seeing this guy in front of
people he's got that celebrity or about
him the rock-and-roll lobby 46 year old
caught the nation's attention
[Music]
he's offbeat social media posts
appealing to a younger generation even
taking a skateboarding at Whataburger
keep in mind that just happened the
frenzy just occurred it was just last
month college-educated adults in an
advanced country with air travel and air
conditioning talking like that in public
it's pretty embarrassing my gosh
but before we get to judgy about it a
confession we did it too Beto's personal
magic distorted our journalistic
objectivity for a second there it may
have been the skateboarding or maybe it
was the weird resemblance to a young
bobby kennedy whatever it was
we lost control like everyone else bado
loves rock and roll says GMA he's not
like everyone else he doesn't do stuffy
speeches or policy programs he's not
gonna bore you with entitlement
projections or some scary stuff about
the Korean Peninsula Beto's got a
skateboard and where's nirvana t-shirts
his vision for this country is 1995 that
was a year he was living way uptown and
this walk-up and working as a Manny and
knew this dude on West 112 Street with
some of the stickiest bud in Manhattan
indica a little heavy but sweet it was a
good time bata wants to bring us back to
that time oh we got a little carried
away sorry about that it all seems so
innocent then back a few weeks ago back
in March of 2019 it was just bado and us
and a dream it was a simpler time we
thought anything was possible then we
thought we could write our own story we
didn't know that even fairy tales end
and one day ours did end the magic
turned to dust bitter in our mouths like
a peyote button or psilocybin tea one
day the music died bye bye miss American
Pie bye-bye weirdly youthful middle-aged
white guy with fake Hispanic nickname
you've been replaced there's a new
heartthrob in cable news he's everything
that you were but more he's younger he's
shallower he's even less experienced
he's got an even weirder name plus he's
gay he's the perfect candidate for
voters who say they love diversity but
don't really want to vote for Stu
the Abrams this candidate could have
been created at a lab at CNN and might
have been there's no stopping a man like
this at least until Election Day on some
level beytagh must know it's over
he's no genius but he can smell it more
than six months before the first votes
are cast in Iowa he is done sure he may
keep raising money probably will this is
one real skill but his political career
is done cue the sad Nirvana playlist so
what are the lessons of the sinking of
the SS bado well here's one maybe you
should have run on something it's pretty
hard to win on charisma alone as Hillary
Clinton recently discovered so why don't
we the one person in the race with real
ideas don't have a few big ideas how
about any idea bait Oh could have tried
that it never seemed to occur to him
instead he just strung together cliches
it was like one of those word games
number a mad libs when you used to play
with your brother on the road trips you
get these long seemingly coherent
sentences that when you read them don't
actually mean anything beta was big on
those here's bado doing that on the
green new deal the green utile calls
that sacrifice and service and scale
those the questions that baito asked
just yesterday at UVA so the question
for the rest of us is our voters ready
to suffer I don't know 400,000 US combat
deaths for the sake of the climate what
does a carbon dioxide Guadalcanal look
like a co2 Saipan when we get to bomb
Tokyo again with fire bombs how would
that affect the temperature come on this
is just too stupid none of this is real
the green new deal isn't a deal it's a
wish fulfillment
posing as legislation but here's the
thing bado kept a straight face
throughout that talk like he really
sincerely meant it who does that well
mediocre people do that mediocre people
tell implausible
and then demand that you pretend to
believe them is bado a mediocre person
we'll let you decide in 2017 beta Roark
gave a total of less than 1% of his
income 1/3 of 1% to be precise to
charity and keep in mind he's rich
very rich here's his explanation for why
he did that in public office since 2005
I do my best to interview to the success
of my community my state and now of my
country there are ways that I do this
that are measurable in their ways I do
this there are charities that we donate
to that we've recorded in my lives
others will be donated to that we have
not but I'll tell you I'm doing
everything I can right now
spending this time with you not with our
kiddos not that cold in El Paso because
I want to sacrifice everything to make
sure that we meet this moment of truth
with everything we've got
ok so save that tape it's on the inner
that's from UVA yesterday and you're
gonna want to download that and keep
that for your grandchildren because bado
pedestrian is he is in so many ways just
it's something that has never been done
or even attempted by any politician
before that is a unique contribution to
American political life bado has just
made the case that his entire life
Beto's entire life is a kind of
charitable donation all of us get the
gift of bado
just because he's here every time bado
speaks it's like endowing a librarian
Burma or curing shingles in Malawi or
battling childhood obesity in Appalachia
or sending sending mosquito nets to the
Congo but the millions every time he
talks when he tweets it's an act of
charity it's something that makes this
world wiser and kinder and more decent
and better smelling but it was such a
good person that he could write himself
off his taxes if he wanted to the IRS
would have to let him his goodness is so
clearly deductible no lawyer would
contest that but bado doesn't do that he
doesn't shirk his duty he'll pay the
extra tax because he cares
the
much now that you think about it it's
almost sad he'll never be President